the silence
is deafening
no patient voices can be heard
[Music]
only the constant bleeping of life
support machines
this is the children's intensive care
unit at st
mary's hospital in central london
but there is no more space here for
critically sick children
this is now a covert 19 icu
full of adults first important to
realize that we're a children's
intensive care unit and as you can see
we're full of adult patients so which
demonstrates the amount of pressure the
system is under
people have said you know this isn't a
problem for children
but the indirect impacts of this
epidemic are affecting children really
badly
the normal health care system that we
have for children in london
is severely affected so i wouldn't say
children are
not being treated properly but clearly
some of their care is compromised
because of the changes we've had to make
to accommodate the adults
just like hospitals across the country
the sheer
volume of admissions means that saint
mary's has been forced to increase its
capacity
and that means new space constantly
needs to be found
to treat a rising number of coveted
patients
i think this is worse than the first
wave i mean we know from the numbers
there are many more patients being
admitted to hospital
and there are many more patients being
admitted to intensive care
and i think the issue is that this peak
whenever it comes is going to take
longer
to dissipate whereas the first wave was
kind of short and sharp
in a way this is going on for longer and
is going to be a higher peak
[Music]
every single patient here except one
is sedated there are 13 patients on this
ward 12 are on incubators
and they're in a coma the doctors are
using ventilators to keep them alive
patients deep in induced comas know
nothing about the tender
devoted care they receive the machines
help their virus infected lungs to
breathe
but everything else has to be done by a
dedicated team
of doctors and nurses this patient
needs to be x-rayed maneuvering an
unconscious heavy adult it's
challenging all right and if i can get
him to come to you all do slightly
all the staff here are trained to treat
sick
children their nurses and their doctors
they've had to learn to transfer their
life-saving skills
to adults the physiotherapists
normally treat children who weigh around
10
kilograms now they're having to prone
adults
who can weigh 10 times as much
the pediatric staff have had to adapt
family liaison nurses joe and helen
have the impossible task of acting as
the only link between these patients
and their desperately worried families
covered covid19 is doubly cruel
taking away lives and any chance
of a final goodbye nothing can really
prepare you for seeing your loved one
in intensive care with all the tubes and
lines and it can be quite scary so
before we do it we have to prepare them
and
you know quite often they're breaking
down on the phone and normally you would
hug them
and and tell them you know we're here
for you
you can't really do that when they're
you know at the other end of a
camera so it's hard and the end of life
situation is the hardest where
we might um allow one family member to
come in
so the family has to decide don't know
joe which family member is going to come
in
we have to wear full ppe and we might
have a facetime
camera so that other family members can
be there
virtually but a year ago
would we ever think that that was normal
to say goodbye to your mum
on an iphone on an ipad whereas now this
is sadly happening quite a lot isn't it
[Music]
we were all hoping desperately that we
wouldn't have to go through this again
um but i think we got through it the
first time
so we know that you know we're we're
hopeful that we'll get through it again
intact thirteen or first together
okay before you're not trying to
wake up
the struggle to find beds to accommodate
other hospital requests to take in their
sick
and this pressure is being felt right
across london's healthcare system
this hospital is not overwhelmed
but it is pretty close
the next few weeks will be critical at
the moment if you look at the community
transmission
it's certainly not rising quite as fast
as it was in some areas it's falling
ever so slightly but i think we need a
few more days to see whether that
continues but even once it starts to
fall we know that the pressure on the
nhs carries on for some weeks after that
and so that's what we're preparing for
are you worried
i'm concerned but i i say i've been so
impressed by
the way that everyone has pulled
together
the hospital's pediatric ward is now
also full of adults with covid19
the emotional toll is beginning to tell
there's one gentleman who was just so
sweet and
we really got to know him quite well and
then he just deteriorated
overnight and passed away and um
he was talking about his boat and things
like that and being on his boat and then
there was pictures of him with his big
steering wheel on the boat and stuff
like that and it just
some reason when he passed away we took
all the pictures down
and i've sort of broke down then
this deadly crisis that has gripped
london shows
no sign of easing it is
real the patients here would say the
same
except they're too sick to tell you
ashish joshi sky news st mary's hospital